Milton is typically sited by literary
historians is one of the first major
English poets to praise in verse,
uh, the institution of marriage. And,
and in this, in this respect, he
seems to have followed Spencer,
a Edmund Spencer who's fairy queen is
in large part a tribute to the sacrament
of marriage. Although
interestingly, the fairy queen, uh,
the Great Spencerian poem,
uh,
never actually manages to feature a,
a marriage between two human beings,
the only marriage that actually appears
there as a marriage between two rivers.
Uh, nonetheless, the fairy queen
can be said, however, strangely,
uh,
that it is the first great
poetic celebration and
English of the institution of
marriage.
Uh,
and this was important to Milton and
one of the big set piece speeches and
paradise lost you,
and you may remember it if you've read
that poem is the hymn that begins hail,
wedded love. And Milton is
adamant throughout the epic in,
in his insistent imagining Adam and eve,
quite specifically as a married
couple and a married couple.
And this is important to Milton,
a married couple with an active sex life.
There are a couple who's marital blessing
has been granted by none other than
God himself.
Now,
the treatise is that Milton wrote on
the rights of divorce and the 1640s are
also, uh, extravagantly. Pro-Marriage.
Um,
a happy marriage for Milton was founded
on a couple's likeminded opinions and
values, their ability to
converse with one another.
And so this is why the notion of the
divorce for reasons of in compatibility is
so important to Milton because
compatibility and melt marriage is,
is the very essence of marriage.
I can only imagine though at
this point in this semester, uh,
what will become Milton's eventual
championing of marriage, um,
is, is pretty hard to imagine a w in part
because we're just devoting our second
class to a literary work given almost
entirely to the virtue of chastity.
And there's every indication that as I,
and I mentioned this before, of course,
there's every indication that Milton
have a lot of these early works bespeak
something like a serious interest,
um,
in the ideal of a lifelong
state of chastity.
And chastity is not only an obsessive
topic in the early poems for Milton, um,
or in the published a treatise
that we looked at last time,
the apology for smack Tim Lewis.
It's also a subject,
uh,
in the reading that we can find in the
reading journal that Melton kept for the
better part of his life.
So the text into which, uh,
any early modern 17th century writer
would jot his or her thoughts into his
reading notes was always called
a commonplace book. And Milton,
uh, like so many of his contemporaries
kept a commonplace book. And, and, and,
and as you can imagine, he kept
it, um, for the most part in Latin.
And actually we have Milton's
commonplace book is reading notes. Um,
and you can find it all in
English translation and volume.
One of the complete prose works of John
Milton. It's a in the CCL collection.
Now one of the entries in
Milton's commonplace book
that touches on the subject
of chastity strikes me as a
particularly charged one four.
It's a terrifying image of,
of, of violence. And I've,
I've never really known what to do
with this. And I think at the entry
can be seen as in some way helpful for
our understanding of this poem, the mask.
So this is what we know.
Sometime in the year 1639,
Milton read a history book entitled the
General General Chronicle of England,
um, in which there was a
discussion in, in disco, in,
in a, in a, in a, in its
treatise on medieval England,
the discussion of a brutal Danish invasion
in the ninth century of a Catholic
convent in the English city of Coldingham.
It's a Milton jots down the historical
deal detail from this account that seems
to have caught his attention.
And this is what,
this is what he knows as
particularly memorable. Uh,
the nun abba cut off her nose and
lips and urge the other sisters,
the other nuns in the
convent to do the same thing.
So that frustrated in this way,
the Danes would make no
attempt against their virtue.
It's the, it's the violence of this
a horrible act of self sacrifice,
tragic act of self sacrifice.
Um,
an act of self sacrifice
intended obviously to preserve
the state of virginity
that, that, that,
that grabs our attention and presumably
grabbed Milton's in order to avoid the
violation of their virginity at the
hands of the brutal Danish Brigans at
believes a conflict convent full of nuns
to disfigure themselves every knows and
lip. Um, as you can imagine,
there's no historical evidence that
anything like this took place in.
It actually seems to be something
of an urban legend among, uh,
among medieval writers, a
recounting, uh, early, uh,
early Christian convents.
This same story, um,
about the nuns deceleration of their nose
and their lips seems to have been told
about just all, um, all of the
early, early Christian nunneries,
uh, a strange cultural fantasy
manifesting itself in some way, but,
but nonetheless, Milton Milton includes
this in is commonplace entry. No,
no commentary, no observation, no
interpretation of it. But, but,
but I think we could make some estimation
of its significance if we juxtapose
it,
uh,
with comas since the mask
attempts to tackle in a much more,
in a much more expanded form.
So many of the same issues.
Comas is an elaborate meditation,
not simply on chastity but,
but also on the threat of rape. And,
and of course as I mentioned last time,
comas himself suggests
nothing more than he,
than wanting to get the lady to
drink a sip from the Chairman Cup.
But it's clear from his language that
the subtext, at least behind his,
his deduction involves in some
way at least an intimation of the,
of the lady sexual submission,
the potential danger a besetting the lady
is certainly a subject of some concern
for her due to full brothers.
You remember they're wandering around
the forest without her picking,
picking berries that the younger brother,
the second brother is most
concerned about his sister's safety.
So I want you to look at this passage.
Um,
this is line three 98 of comas,
page 99 in the Hughes. So the,
the second brother says that the,
the lady is an open target
out there for an assault.
You may as well spread out the unsend
heaps of misers treasure by an outlaws
den.
And tell me it is safe as bid me hope.
Danger will wink on
opportunity. We'll, we'll,
we'll not allow itself to see opportunity
and let a single helpless maiden pass
uninjured in this wild surrounding waste.
So, so notice first year that
the younger brother compares, uh,
compares his sister, his virginity
to a misers treasure. Um,
and in this particularly odd image, you
have something like a veiled accusation.
And it's not unlike comas, his
accusation that the lady is hoarding her,
her God given treasurer of
her chastity, and the, with,
with all of the resonances that the of
the parable of the talents that, that,
that we see in comas,
a similar language,
but you also notice the
sense of limitation and the
vulnerability associated
with the physical state of virginity here.
As wonderful as the
ladies chastity might be,
it's certainly not going to protect her
from the dangers lurking in this wild
surrounding waste.
And if anything,
her chastity will only
attract such injuries as,
as we saw in the last lecture,
the elder brother holds an entirely
different theory of, of chastity.
And of course it's a lot more optimistic.
Um, he believes that the, that a virgin,
like the lady is secure or safe from
the violent attacks imagined by as a
younger brother.
So look at line four,
23 of Comas,
uh,
where the elder brother explains that
the chase lady can actually travel
anywhere. She pleases utterly
unafraid. She may trace huge forests.
I mean,
both.
Both of these positions are voice was
such a magnificently hyperbolic rhetoric.
She may trace huge forests
and an harbored heats,
infamous hills and
sandy parallettes wilds.
We're through the res, the sacred
rays of chastity. No savage,
fierce bandit or mountain ear will
dare to soil her virgin purity.
He dismisses his brother's entirely
practical argument because for him,
chastity is a lot more than it's a
simple exercise of sexual abstinence.
It's a positive for us and it exerts a,
an actual and somehow palpable
discernible force in the world.
The sacred rays of chastity are going
to be emanating from the chase to maiden
and protecting our lumps like
some magical force field.
And actually we'll keep her safe from
the physical assaults of a savage bandit
or a mountaineer.
Now.
Now this is just a thought
exercise. Um, but we're,
we're the elder brother to
read the general chronicle
of England that Milton had
read in 1639. I am assuming he
would have found in coherent the,
the story that had so interested in
Milton that the story about St Ebo,
the nun who had, um, who had,
who was driven to such terrible lengths
to protect herself and her fellow
sisters in the nunnery from attack for
the elder brother Ebis bodily purity
should excel, exudes a sufficiently
powerful strength that the,
that the terrible Danes would be repelled
by the sacred rays of her chastity.
Um, so you get something
like a conflict, uh,
developing Milton in Milton's mask
attention between the extravagant virgin
virgin oil, idealism of
the, of the elder brother.
And what I have to concede as the much
more practical sense of virginities
limitations, uh, voiced by
the, by the second brother.
And so Milton is actually
staging a debate,
but between these two positions
enacted on the stage in 1634 by an a
nine and nine and an 11 year old boy,
I'll remind you, but
the very presence, uh,
but the very presence in a theatrical
piece of a, of a long and weighty,
a philosophical debate like this one,
um,
could easily be seen as having
a pretty tedious effect. And,
and Milton is taking a
pretty great risk here.
And so it's worth asking what's at
stake, uh, because this is such an odd,
an odd thing to find.
And so I want to consider a way in which
this debate between these two brothers
can be seen as related to other debates.
Um,
other conflicts between
competing aspects of, of,
of Milton's own consciousness
that would be one perspective and,
and maybe more grandly between opposing
factions in the, in the culture of,
of 17th century England at large.
First though,
I need to say a couple of
words about the word chastity.
Um, as I've been using it throughout
this, throughout the discussion,
so far of comas,
both,
both today and Monday up to this point.
Um,
and some of you may have felt this,
I've been throwing the word chastity
around a little promiscuously and, and,
and throwing it around with
this kind of looseness. Um,
I've been reproducing what I take to be
a certain sloppiness in Milton's text.
Um,
I,
I've been speaking of chastity
as if chastity and virginity,
we're were absolute synonyms or
are always synonyms just to, uh,
uh, forever interchangeable. And this
simply isn't true in the 17th century.
Um, now it goes without saying
that we all know what virginity is.
Virginity is that bodily
state that predates inactive
of sexual intercourse and
therefore for, at least for
most of Milton's contemporaries,
that is the bodily state that
predates marriage. Chastity,
however,
was beginning to mean something new in
the period for a lot of Protestants in
the early 17th century.
The word chastity could also be used
to refer to this state of what could be
called married chastity and Mary Chaston.
He was a type of bodily purity that could
be extended or in spiritual purity as
well that can be extended even to into
marriage. This is sort of the theory.
If a,
if a couple of practice temperate moderate
and more or less dispassionate act of
sexual intercourse,
they could be said to remain chaste.
A married couple of course they could
keep for themselves the prestigious title
of chase even though they were obviously
performing an act that almost anyone in
an earlier period would assume
disqualified them, um, from, from the,
from being,
from being called chaste.
And so their opens up a kind of
distinction between virginity,
which is of course actual physical,
sexual,
abstinence and chastity,
which for some could actually include
the moderate practice of sex within,
within marriage.
And it's one of the interesting and
curious features of the Protestant mask
comas that this is a distinction
that's never really observed or,
or,
or acknowledged.
Virginity and chastity seemed to be
used often and kind of awkwardly,
I think interchangeably. And the
confusion between these two words, um,
is closely related.
I propose to the,
some of the confusions and dilemmas
confronted by the work as a whole.
And I'll go so far as to say that some
of the semantic difficulty here in the,
in our understanding of the word
chastity has something to do with an
indisputable,
indisputably awkward element of Comas,
this plot.
And that's the fact that for so much of
this mask, the lady is stuck to receipt.
Okay.
So I mentioned at the beginning of the
lecture that Milton would go on to become
the English languages premier poet of,
of marriage.
But it's important to note that the
celebration of marriage is not at all an
obvious thing for,
for an English poet and Milton's
time to be a attempting to,
to strive toward.
And in fact,
it's just at this point in early modern
England that that marriage is beginning
to assert itself as a,
as a cultural ideal,
uh,
uh, religiously inflected cultural ideal
through it throughout their renaissance,
uh, throughout the 16th century. The
popular ideas about marriage and celibacy,
we're still firmly tied to the values
of the Roman Catholic Church. Uh,
well after the actual reformation,
the Roman doctrine of course had
prized the state of Celibacy, um,
insisting that it was the superior
state, um, over marriage. Now,
it's true that,
and this has always been the case,
that a proper marriage was obviously
always one of the churches,
sacraments and marriage obviously had
always received the church's blessing.
But nonetheless, the higher ideal was
still seem to be celibacy. And it was,
it was the ideal, uh,
embraced by priests and nuns.
And it was the ideal to which
all Christians theoretically,
at least should shouldn't.
We're in a position to,
to aspire to it.
It's in the period that,
that Milton is writing in a,
it's in the period in which
Milton has writing that the, that,
that the tide is beginning to turn.
And so the Protestant reformation
and especially, uh, the,
the risings energies of puritanism in the
early 17th century are beginning to do
a lot to change this state of affairs.
And so over the course of the century,
you can see a gradual as if something
like this could actually be charted.
Nonetheless,
I think it's safe to say you see a gradual
decline in the cultural idealization
of virginity and a corresponding increase
in the valuation of marriage and this
new form of chastity that we can
think of as married chastity. Um,
it's a transition in the
valuation of, uh, of,
of marriage that is not at
all an easy one. However,
um, there, there are debates,
there are disagreements even
among puritans about which state,
virginity or married chastity
is the superior one, um,
in the eyes of God.
And it's an in,
in light of this ongoing cultural
tension in the period, um,
that I think we can understand some
of the strange confusions concerning
chastity that we, that we
find in, in the, in the,
in the poem that we're looking at now,
one of the moments in which the,
this tension between virginity and
chastity seems to be most pronounced is in
the encounter between Columbus and the
lady that we looked at in the last class.
A comas attempts to seduce
the lady you'll remember with,
with something like an economic theory of,
of natural beauty for comas.
Nature has given us all of
her riches and it's our duty.
It's our obligation to spend them,
to consume them, to consume the,
to Lug luxuriate in
natures, uh, generosity.
You can think of this and this
has actually been described, uh,
by,
by critics as something like an
aristocratic theory of natural expenditure
because comas imagines in this
fantasy rhetorical world of his,
something like an almost endless
supply of natural wealth, um,
nature's wealth can continually
and forever be spent and expended.
Now,
the lady responds to coma,
says what we can think of is
his aristocratic debauchery
with an economic theory
of our own. And we haven't looked at that
yet. So this is line seven 68 of comas.
And in the Hughes Edition, it's on
page 108. This is the ladies a retort.
She explains that nature of course,
wants us to live according to her
sober laws and holy dictate of spare
temperance.
And in this description of the moderate
and temperate enjoyment of nature,
the ladies giving us something like a,
uh,
a puritan economic theory.
And so this is her argument line seven 68
if every just man that now pines with
want headbutt a moderate and besieging
share of that which lucidly
pump pampered luxury. Now,
heaps upon some few with vast access.
Nature's full blessings would be well
dispensed in unsuppressed Louis even
proportion.
It's,
I think it's sometimes hard to remember
in reading his speech like this,
that the ladies actually talking
about Justin, he, her argument sounds,
and some of you may
recognize this argument.
It sounds so distinctly like a political
argument and argument from political
economy. And it actually, it's been
shown, um, seems to foreshadow the, uh,
the political philosophy of, of Milton's
much younger contemporary John Locke.
Uh, the, the notion that nature
demands that every human individual,
uh, has just enough is given just
enough to be self sufficient.
But when you remember that the subject
at hand is actually in some way sex,
then you can begin to associate the lady's
image of this moderate consumption of
natural wealth with some version of,
if this makes sense, some version
of an act of sexual consummation.
The ladies called call
for, uh, a tempered,
a moderate distribution and
con consumption of natural
goods seems to point us
towards something like a
particular attitude toward sex.
And this [inaudible],
this is sex she's seeming to refer to it.
It's clearly not
virginity that's at stake.
And this isn't sexual abstinence that
the lady's pointing to a with revision of
the moderate and temperate
enjoyment of nature's beauty.
The lady is sketching this
new 17th century ideal of, of,
of married chastity,
the ideal of the temperate,
moderate indulgence in sexual pleasure,
pleasure of course,
within the sanctified confines
of marriage. And, and,
and this makes sense. We have to assume
that the lady is resisting comas,
his advances because she has before her
the higher ideal of married chastity.
One day she will become
a wife herself and it's,
it's in her husband that she will
eventually invest the talent of her bodily
wealth. To use the metaphor
that we get from Matthew 25,
it's a perfectly reasonable sentiment to
include an an example of the particular
genre that Milton is writing.
This mask in the form of this
mask is that of the romance.
It's a literary genre that,
that that dates back to classical Greece,
late classical Greece,
and which typically charged the trials
and tribulations of a hero in many cases,
the trials and tribulations
of a virginal heroin.
The romance heroin is often
threatened with rape, um,
but by her cleverness or by good
luck or concatenation of forces, um,
she can always invariably avert that
tragedy. And by the end of the work,
she can present herself to her
future husband as, as a virgin.
And, and, and this,
this last twist is without question
the central element of the convention,
the Conventional Romance Plot.
And this remains a central element in
the Harlequin Romances for example,
that are, that are still I think
consumed. Um, so voraciously,
even today after her brush with danger
after her brush with sexual peril,
the romance heroin always gets married in
the end, the story has to end that way.
And her marriage is invariably seen as
her reward for all the trouble she's been
through.
Now,
given this the romance frame of
Milton's comas where we're not surprised
actually to see,
even though we don't see at the
end her actually getting married,
we're not surprised to see the lady in
this speech embracing a form of chastity,
that that promise is something
like an eventual turn to marriage.
This makes sense. And it's with
this hint at the state of marriage,
chastity, you know, kind of this,
it seems like a healthy
perspective. Um, it's,
it's with this hint that the lady ended
her speech at the only 17th century
performance in comas,
which as you know,
took place at Ludlow Castle in 1634
on McComas night at this original
performance of the mask, the lady speech
read by the Lady Alice Edgerton, age 15,
um, ended at line seven 79 in, in,
in your text. And, and I think after
hearing the lady enter speech at nine,
seven 79 that the audience
could reasonably expect
that the lady would someday
get married. But yeah, you can see from
the text that you have in your hues,
additions or any addition.
Um, and he printed edition.
Now the speech continues in the
version of the mask that, that we,
that we have while Milton wrote most of
the mask in 1634 he published it in 1637
and it's at this 0.3 years later that he
seems to have inserted into the lady's
speech and also elsewhere in the
poem, um, for, for this certain lines,
for the published version.
So the lady's speech and the
printed version continues
at line seven 79 and this
is what the lady asks,
how can you not love this?
Shall I go on or have I said enough?
Clearly Milton is instead of the way a
wonderfully speaking through the lady
here,
but then we get the lady again,
shall I go on or have I said enough to
him that dares arm his profane tongue
with contemptuous words against the
sun cloud power of chastity thing.
Would I something say yet to what end
thou has nor ear nor soul to apprehend the
sub sublime notion and high mystery that
must be uttered to unfold the sage and
serious doctrine of virginity.
She's speaking reluctantly here.
She'd love to tell calmness
something about chastity, but he has,
he has neither ear nor soul
to apprehending the sublime
notion and high mystery.
Okay.
The speeches as proceeding
rather smoothly.
And I think kind of Vic's
explicably as the lady defense,
The sun cloud power of chastity. Uh, but,
but look at the end of the passage
that I've just read a few lines down.
The doctrine that the lady
wishes to advance suddenly
seems so absolutely not to
be a doctrine of Mary chastity.
It's the,
it's the sage and serious doctrine.
The virginity that concludes the speech.
It's clear that something's
happened between 1634 and 1637. Uh,
Milton's lady doesn't proceed as we
expect her to talk to Marshall for their
arguments for the, for the
moderate fulfillment of one's
conjugal obligations. Uh,
there, there's no more talk of temperate
sex or the virtuous and moderate,
the virtuous moderation that's so
important to the ideal of Mary chastity.
And The lady begins to speak instead
of the unyielding virtue of sexual
abstinence. That's absolutely central to
an entirely different kind of doctrine.
The doctrine of, of, of
virginity. So we have to ask
this question. What's happened?
The lady has claimed that she's
hesitant to say anything at this point.
Tacoma's how could such a double edged
character possibly understand the
mysterious truths about chastity?
She re interestingly,
she refuses to unfold for her audience.
The Sagent serious doctrine of divinity.
Okay.
Of Virginity.
Um,
but she does anticipate what that doctrine
of virginity would look like if she
were to unfold it.
She explains to comas what would happen
should she actually choose to break her
silence,
should she actually choose to unleash
all of the rhetorical powers that she has
pent up inside of her? And,
and, and in some important way,
I think the lady can be seen as being in
the same position that Milton had been,
had been representing himself in.
And so many of the early poems,
he was continually imagining himself
to be someone on the verge of saying
something spectacular, but he
wasn't. He wasn't quite there yet.
But the lady continues.
Look at line seven 92.
Thou art not fit to hear
thy self convinced yet.
Should I try and she means shit. Should
I try voice the doctrine of virginity,
the uncontrolled worth of this pure cause
would kindle my rap spirits to such a
flame of sacred vehemence that dumb
things would be moved to sympathize and
their brut earth would lend her nerves
and shake till all by magic structures
weird so high were shattered
into heaps or thy false head.
She's making us a strong acclaim as, as
possible to make for the, for the, for,
for her potential for rhetorical power.
She implies that she's the equal,
uh,
to any of the great poetic heroes that
Milton so admires as a virginal order.
Should she choose to unleash your powers.
Um,
she would have the power of an Orpheus.
I'm moving dumb things to sympathize
Orpheus being one of Milton's most prized
mythological figures of the,
of the powerful poet.
She'd have the strength of a Samson,
the biblical hero who could shatter
huge structures over the heads of his
enemies.
She has way more power than she needs.
It would seem to destroy a petty
little may just like comas.
The power that the lady claims for herself
as a virgin is, is, is, is titanic.
And it allows us to understand,
I think,
why she has slipped
from her discussion of,
of married Chassidy to this new
discussion of what seems to be,
or what she claims is virginity it the
lapse makes a certain kind of sense.
I think because it's virginity and it's,
and not married chastity,
that the lady imagines will allow her to
demonstrate such a remarkable show of,
of rhetorical strength. It's, it's,
it's almost apocalyptic
in, in its force. Um, it,
it promises something like the power
of God is he brings the, the, the, the,
the shattering close of the
entire Christian narrative, uh,
t to an end at the, at the last
judgment and beyond. Um, and, and,
and one of the,
one of the cultural phenomena fueling,
I think this rhetorical bursts of the
ladies is the prevalence 17th century, um,
anticipation of the end of the
world, the millennium, the,
the, the, all of these, uh,
uh, apocalyptic, uh,
beliefs that were swirling
around almost all of the,
a sectarian,
a sectarian religious
figures in the 17th century.
So,
given all of these cultural resonances,
there's a lot riding on the lady's
claim for her rhetorical powers here.
And, and you can understand that
initial hesitation when she asks,
shall I go on or have I said enough? She's
probably said way more than enough. Uh,
uh,
in her testimony to the potentially
apocalyptic power of her virginal speech.
She, she's, she's making extraordinary
claims for virgin and oratory.
And it has all of the power of,
of prophecy that Milton had had been
associating with a biblical prophets.
But, but as, as I've mentioned before,
she doesn't deliver
this anticipated speech.
And so virginities power remains untested.
W We,
we can't know just what force
virginity would exude. And,
and so the speech leaves
us where we begin, um,
in a state of uncertainty concerning
the ultimate strength of this virtue of,
of, of sexual abstinence. It leaves
this where we began asking what finally,
what is virginity good for?
We're reproducing a, the
problem that the, that the,
that the two brothers were
rehearsing in their debate.
So the lady in the 1637 vision version
of this poem of this mask is at an
impasse.
She stuck between a competing
ideals of bodily purity, uh,
just as just as surely and as
firmly as she is stuck to her seat.
And, uh, this is a,
this is a kind of a literary metal
literary allegories ation that I'll be
performing here.
But you could also think of Milton,
the poet as being stuck at this.
At this same juncture,
he stuck between two meanings of chastity.
Chastity has absolute virginity and
chastity as the moderate and besieging
sexuality sanction within marriage.
And he's also stuck between two models
of speech with which we have become quite
familiar by this point. On the one hand,
he's, he wants to wait before he talks.
He wants to keep anticipating
producing the great speech, uh,
which is exactly what the lady has
been doing. But on the other hand,
Milton's possessed of a competing desire
to speak and to speak now to publish,
uh, to succeed, to consummate
his hat, his talents.
And it's as if Milton were paralyzed
almost at this moment in his choice,
uh,
between these various alternatives.
Now we know that the lady doesn't
end the masks happily us imagine how,
but it would be like
if this were the case,
she doesn't end the mask
stuck Tacoma's chair.
And it's important to figure out
exactly how the lady gets unstuck.
And so that's what we're going to
look at. Now. This is the [inaudible].
Remember there's first the bungled attempt
by the two brothers to release her.
Um, they forget to reverse. Comas
is won when they rushed into,
when they rushed him to his
layer. That didn't pan out. Um,
they had even obtained with the help of
the attendance spirit, the magical herbs,
Haman knee with all of
its Homeric associations.
But this too seemed inadequate to
the task of rescuing their sister.
The lady is only rescued once the
attendant spirit calls on the Nymph.
Sabrina the genius Loci,
the natural spirit of the Severn stream,
that which is the river that separates
England from Wales and Milton uses for
his source, for the
character. Sabrina, um,
another character named Sabrina
from Spencer's the fairy queen.
There's a wonderful work of literary
criticism. I mentioned it last time, um,
on Milton's indebtedness to Spencer,
um,
in the book by John Guillory
called Poetic Authority.
I urge you to look at it if
you're interested in, um,
the, the fact that Sabrina,
this little character here has her origin
and Spencer's important. Uh, Spencer's,
the great early Christian Poet
in English of Holy Matrimony.
Um, and, uh, according to
Gillery is brilliant argument.
Um,
he has the power to counteract.
Spencer does the magical
effect that Shakespeare wields
through the character of
comas. The lady had claimed for
herself a remarkable set of powers,
but she wasn't yet ready to use them.
She was paralyzed in speech just as just
as she was prevented from even moving.
And it was almost as if a sobrinas a
sent from the Severn stream to assist the
lady in her time of need
suggests Spencer's arrival
from the realm of English
literature to assist the
young poet John Milton,
Edmund Spenser arrives,
arises to help Milton
overcome the paralyzing effect
of the comas like power of Shakespeare.
Uh,
let's see if this makes any sense.
Uh, look at line eight 52 of comas.
This is page 110 in the Hughes.
The attendant experience,
the attendant spirit
explains that sobrinas in,
in possession of precious vialed
liquors that have the capacity to heal.
So at line eight 52 up,
Sabrina can unlock the clasping charm and
thaw the numbing spell if she be right
invoked and warbled song for maidenhood
she loves and will be swift to aid a
virgin such as was herself
in hard besetting need this.
Will I try and add the power
of some ad during verse?
The power reverse has everything to do
with the power wielded by Sabrina to save
the lady from,
from her paralysis.
If if right invoked in warbled song,
Sabrina can actually be called
down for assistance. Um, and,
and it's just this or called up for
assistance and it's just this interest in
the right, the proper form of warbled
song that's so important here.
She resists represents a power that
might enable Milton to warble a right or
proper song. She represents a power that
might enable Milton. Perhaps someday.
Actually to fulfill,
to consummate his,
his much anticipated poetic promise.
But how does she do that?
Look at line 910.
This is page 111 in the Hughes.
Sabrina says to the lady,
she rises from the water,
Brightest Lady, look on me.
Thus I sprinkle on my breasts,
drops that from my fountain pure.
I have kept of precious
cure thrice upon my fingers.
Tip Thrice upon the ruby lip.
Next,
this marble marble venom
seat smeared with gums,
have glutenous heat.
I touch with chased palms moist and cold.
Now, if this is a, this is a, if this
is a scene as it's been argued of,
of Sabrina's baptism of the lady, it's
a, it's a curious baptism. Indeed,
we might think that the,
that sobrinas chased palms moist and
cold would only make more frigid and more
frozen, uh, the the body
of the lady. But in fact,
it's just the opposite that happens.
Um,
I think of the delicate, really beautiful
sensuality here and sobrinas speech.
I don't think we were expecting this.
Uh,
she evokes the beauty
of the ladies Ruby Blip.
How inappropriate the eroticization of
the ladies beauty has up to this point
come exclusively from comas. And in
and in touching the lady's fingers tip.
It's as if Sabrina were awakening the
first time, the lady sense of, of,
of touch.
Now the lady we know has an exquisite
and powerful sense of hearing.
Uh, she's a poet and she
has an impeccable ear,
but this fiercely virginal lady
has not up to up to this point,
even begun to develop
her other sensory realms.
And when Sabrina touches the surprisingly
sensual ruby lip of the lady,
she's an essence baptizing,
I think in sanctioning the erotic drives
that the lady has been so fiercely
repressing.
She baptizes the entire domain of non
auditory sensual experience that the lady
so forcefully avoids. And you can think
of Sabrina as she touches so gently.
The lady, this is the, this is to use the,
uh,
the wonderful phrase that John Guillory
used actually in this very room when I
was a, when I took the Milton
mature as an undergraduate.
That's what Sabrina is doing is,
uh, and this dates John Gallery.
This is a very seventies phrase,
but Sabrina is activating the lady's
erogenous zones and there's something,
there's, there's, there's
something to that with,
with this magical touching of the
lady with their precious liquor.
Sabrina's saves the lady
from her paralysis and,
and Milton stage directions. Just
say at all. It's very simple. Uh, uh,
the lady just rises out of her seat.
I don't want to suggest that the,
that sobrinas work is purely erotic hair.
There's a lot more than sex implied in
this redemptive touching and touching the
ladies ruby lip.
She's also,
I think releasing the ladies hesitation
to speak after after comas is masterful
seduction replete with all of
its illusions to the, to the, uh,
the parable of the
talents from Matthew 25.
The lady you'll remember had
been so hesitant to speak.
I had not thought to have unlocked my
lips in this unhallowed air and when she
does unlock our lips ever so slightly
when she doesn't lock our lips, uh,
she does do only to anticipate the effect
that our speeches would have if she
were to unlock them even more.
Um,
everything is entirely
conditional and future oriented.
Sobrinas touching of the ladies lip,
uh,
seems to unlock perhaps permanently
the rhetorical hesitation that has
paralyzed, uh, the lady and
the lady is, is, is liberated.
Uh, of course we have no evidence
of the ladies rhetorical liberation.
There's no, there's no further
speech on her part. Um,
but it's an important action.
I think nonetheless, the
touching of the ladies rip,
the touching of the ladies lip touches
us in, in, in other ways as well though,
at least in this lecture because we
remember that, uh, that unfortunate,
that horrifying image of,
of the lip that Milton had
noted in the commonplace book,
St Abba Abba had not
only severed her nose,
she had also severed her lip.
And I think it's worth thinking about,
at least for a moment,
um,
of the oddity of this terrible act
of self mutilation, the Superflow,
his action suggest that there was
something more at stake perhaps than C
[inaudible] attempt to ward off
sexual assault to disfigure the mouth.
This is how I would
interpret it to disfigure.
The mouth has a primary
effect in rendering one,
at least temporarily speechless.
And I think there's a connection here
between the image from the commonplace
book and the treatment in Milton's
mask of this strange strangely can join
phenomenon of virginity and speechlessness
and the little scene from the early
English history that Milton
had selected from his reading.
You have an image of silencing of a,
of a,
of a horrifying and unredeemable
speechlessness that is
so closely connected to
virginity. And it would seem
to be the terrible thing of,
of Saint [inaudible] to die,
both speechless and virginal that
Milton is struggling to avoid here.
So yeah,
Columbus is a celebration of virginity
and it might even be a celebration of
Milton's endlessly anticipatory mood,
the mood of,
of imaging himself as
a, as, as a great poet.
But th but these virtues,
however great I think are also associated
in the mask with the ladies Petro
faction,
her,
her fixation on the seat that
Comis has has fashioned for her.
And it's one of the duties
of the masks plot, uh,
to get the lady out of her seat.
And you,
and you can see in the song that the
Sabrina's sings something of the mechanism
perhaps by which this transition is,
is affected. Uh, look at line eight 97.
We're almost done here.
Sabrina rises from the water and
appears gradually on the land making a
transition a lot like the one the
lady will eventually have to make.
She sings sobrinas sings whilst
from off the water's fleet.
Thus I set my print lists
feet or the cows slips,
velvet head that Ben's not as I trend now,
her feet are of course print lists
because she's Arie and a theorial and she
leaves no tread on the
cowl slips or the flowers.
But this is an odd phrase.
You'll concede parentless feet and,
and it's odd. This is
important. Feed of course,
has a lot of meanings
and Milton's poetic feet.
The material of the verse written in,
in six and eight and 10
syllables in this poem, um,
are also in 1634 print lists there.
They're unpublished.
And when comas is first
perform per first perform,
Milton's poetry hasn't yet been printed.
Um,
but it's almost as if Sabrina,
um,
seems to have died print
lists or unpublished so that
Milton wouldn't have to,
um, it's a sacrifice on, on, on our
poet's behalf. That would be one, uh,
literarily allegorical way to think
of it. Now, as I noted earlier,
there's a difference between the two
existing texts of Milton's comas.
There's the performance version of 1634
and the printed version of 37. And,
and the additions to the texts that Milton
is making for the published version,
uh, reflect, I think he's since that
he liked the lady is in process,
in the process of making
an important transition.
He is no longer or no longer
wants to be an infants.
I'm a poetic virgin,
a speechless poet.
There's also another, another
transition that he's making. Um,
and this, this involves the subject
of virginity not as speechlessness,
but his actual abstinence. The,
the final. Um, and I'll just, uh,
I'll just point you quickly to
this passage. Look at line 1003.
It's on page 113 in the Hughes.
After we have the lady
wandering through the forest,
she joins her father with
her brothers and we get this,
but far above in spangled
sheen celestial cupid,
her fame son advanced
holds his dear psyche,
Sweden tranced after her wandering
Labor's long till free consent,
the gods among make her his eternal bride.
Uh,
you can see an image here of cupids
eventual marriage to psyche as a pointed
reference to the,
the,
the likelihood that the lady to will
will become someone's eternal Brian. Um,
in 1634 in the first version,
we didn't have this anticipation of,
of the ladies for future
marriage. This, this didn't exist.
The lily remained much more fixed in
her idealization of virginity and a lot
more silent in her responses to comas.
But it's almost as if the prospect of
publishing this mask seems to have induced
in Milton and interest in trying to move
beyond the idealization of virginity,
um,
beyond simply the
anticipation of future power.
Um,
and you're,
you're getting to see something
like an intimation of John Milton,
the published poet,
a poet whose energies are going to be
directed toward making his poems public.
The poet of anticipation is beginning
to think of himself as the poet of
achievement.
And the poet of the radical
power of virginity is
beginning to redirect a lot of
his interests to the radical pair,
the radical power of married sexuality.
Now,
it won't be another four or five
years after the publication of,
of calmness that Milton will
himself actually be married.
But the transition from virginity to
marry chastity charted in this poem that
we'd been looking at nonetheless
reflects a marked interest in the nature,
not only of Milton's personal life, but
in the nature of his literary interests.
He's beginning to put aside all of
those literary anxieties induced by his
reading of Shakespeare.
And it's as if he's more and more willing
to use as a kind of literary assistant
or Helper Spencer,
the great,
the Great Poet of Holy Matrimony
and married sexual bliss.
And in the works that Milton is going
to be publishing now with greater and
greater frequency.
It's this Spin Siri and ideal of marriage
that will be the new, and believe me,
that endlessly complex
miltonic subject now for, um,
for, for next time we'll
be reading lists at us, uh,
which is about the death of a friend
and a death of a friend. In fact,
two died a virgin. We have to assume,
um, it's not about marriage and it will,
a marriage will still seem quite a
quite a ways off. I fear when you read,
listen to us.
Um,
but we will be marking the transition
to the poetry of marriage soon enough.
Listen,
this is probably the most difficult poem
linguistically that we'll be reading
all semester. Um, it repays in
numerable readings and re readings.
So I urge you to read it a 75 times,
let's say, before you come to
class on Monday. Thank you.